gk cas de présenter c'est la première
fois qu'il va venir dans tpm pays c'est
une cousine un mois ouais voilà elle est
venue de jacques launay quoi c'est vrai
ouais elle est venue expressément pour
toi c'est sarah du bled voilà qui est
avec nous ce soir on a cueilli sa radio
[Applaudissements]
à savoir si beau gosse est une merveille
de l'humanité changé avance éric ondulé
connu il avait la moquette sur les
cheveux là c'est du parquet sadly
[Applaudissements]
schiffrin par contre tombalbaye tourne
toi un peu c'est quoi ce style c'est
quoi tu fais quoi tu es un animateur ou
tu fais pour la 12e' le café pour la
douce pour tapas qui fait j'aime pas le
style du style je vais te dire que j'ai
vu que tu m pour la route une fois tu
mets en délire comme ça a laissé faire
effet oui ça va mal je suis contente de
l'avant alors je vous explique tout le
monde moi j'ai un resto couscous
boulette karaoké dans le 20e
arrondissement à paris témoigne
ces habitations s'étaient d'esquiver les
boulettes et pour ça les cheveux un
méli-mélo j'étais voulons c'est vrai
cyril j'ai un cadeau pour toi
bah ouais en parlant de mon resto ouais
je tairai amener une petite sucrerie et
mon plaisir sucré fait pas maintenant
parce qu'elles n'ont alors alors je vais
te dire quelque chose qui à part l'été
aux syriens affûté je pourrais parler
c'est bien tu es au sommet en fait tu
veux alors on va distribuer les mac
route après par contre je t'explique
beinheim pas de ma croûte
j'ai dû la black list et dure histoire
mais ce bout là tu m'as volé du goulag
ce jour je suis allé dans la cuisine je
les trouvais la tête dans la gamelle
[Applaudissements]
jlm airgas tu lui donnes fonction des
merguez et l'aubaine djamel castola
bonneveine charmel mon ex-mari sur
voulait elle avait quand même ben dhia
mais la même discipline germain qui
savent pourquoi ils vous ment sur son
identité
non non c'est benjam sm leader explique
si je suis venu c'est pas anodin du
monde d'accord moi je suis aussi une
star de la chanson robles émotions et
j'ai écouté ton single lequel on va à la
pêche aux ouais et alors qu'est ce que
tu vas pêcheurs rouillacaise woippy sous
des cordes vocales ou 10 pour deux
chansons elle est super j'adore la
chanson millavois ainsi paulhacois la
donne mais à quoi fait en annonçant va
pas faut que tu manges ciboulette plus
du goût les âges et tous les jours je te
jure du coup moi ce que j'ai dit et moi
on va dire ce que j'ai décidé de faire
avec talent on va te montrer ce qu'il
est chanteuse
on va te montrer on a repris nos aussi
le mondial à la
[Musique]
serions pas
une lettre les dribbles et aller en
finale
on chantait mon cher année quand le sa
perte et hulu ambulances et les bretons
et man
[Applaudissements]
tentures odeur du pagire y aller sur le
terrain des bas rouges alors p
quand on ouvre une boîte est attirée sur
10 laitiers d'éveil secousse est tombé
elle sait rien
vois tu aimais twitter il assure ne pas
connaître
mais ce matin là
sabah moi que moi non plus
[Musique]
c'est sûr qu'à une lettre à les perdre
cohen
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous
là
[Applaudissements]